all kinds of garbage litter miramar
beach in Mozambique's capital Maputo a
group of a couple dozen volunteers spend
their Saturday collecting the garbage
the man responsible for the clean-up
operation is environmentalist Carlos
Sarah jr. since forming last year the
group has removed garbage from four
provinces in 15 cleanup operations like
this they share the results immediately
via Facebook and whatsapp cuantos
Temujin when we first announced on
social media that we are going to do a
cleanup no one cared but now we've
already done 15 and when we announce it
now people say look those people don't
stop so I'm also going to think twice
before I throw my trash away trash
obscures mozambique's natural beauty
with no public trash cans at the beach
garbage can quickly grow sorting through
the sand for bits of broken glass is a
tedious task the 25 year old Malraux de
brito believes it has to be done don't
throw by naseem you really believe
you'll be able to clean up this entire
Beach Bay starving well I would like to
leave it really clean I will do as much
as I can what I cannot do is do nothing
and leave this class in office in our
than a they shall do that I can at least
make some small improvement at the
Mozambican Ministry of Land environment
and rural development Carlos Sarah
junior heads the legal team responsible
for environmental policies and
legislation he says his work has become
more effective since he joined the
ministry in 2015 grenache hospital
public assume it's a matter of putting
the government machinery into motion and
it works it's much easier for an
institution like this ministry to
approach other public and private
institutions or civil society
organisations and mobilize them for a
common cause see that sea view keisha
knowledge but like I was a cocoon around
15 kilometers away from miramar
each the mangroves which act as natural
filters on the coast are also clogged up
with trash Carlos tells the activists
that garbage not properly disposed of in
urban areas has a direct impact on
marine life once fish and other
inhabitants of the sea feed on it
activists and law student leopoldina
gouveia reacted immediately which team
do it was it was an instinct I can't eat
fish anymore I just can't I haven't got
the courage because to eat fish is to
eat trash because the fish eat the
garbage we throw into the sea the
animals eat the waste we throw away
Carlos Sara jr. wants to change
society's mentality concerning how
people deal with waste he wants mozem
beacons to understand the value of
nature and appreciates its beauty as he
does in probate is important to
contribute to a process of change to
help people stop doing things the same
old way to show that doing nothing is
very wrong it won't be rabble but it
could take some time for environmental
awareness to become the norm here
judging by this weekend the activists
still have a lot of work to do to keep
mozambique's beaches clean
you